- [Narrator] A sun salutation
is a series of continuous yoga poses
to improve your strength
and your flexibility.
Bring your hands to heart center
and set an intention, such as,
I am love, or, I will be strong.
Raise your arms towards the ceiling
and ground down through your feet.
Mountain Pose is a foundational pose.
Hinge at your hips, bring
your fingertips to the floor,
and keep a slight bend in your knees.
This is Forward Fold.
Bring your fingertips to your
shins and flatten your back.
Halfway Lift Pose is a pose for alignment.
Make sure your wrists
and elbows are in line,
arms by your sides, bring your knees
to the floor, and then lower down.
This is modified Chaturanga
Pose for strengthening.
Put your hips towards
the sky and press back.
This is a Downward-Facing Dog.
Step your feet towards your hands,
hang for a moment, then
come back to Mountain Pose,
and bring your palms to heart center.
(soothing upbeat music)
(metal creaking)